Good evening.
I'm gonna say that one more time. This is a crowd participation
question.
Good evening.
Thank you. And you guys pick up so quickly. It's very encouraging
for a speaker. My name
is Phil Sally. I'm the pastor of discipleship and
community and this is our first night of a
string of about 13 equipping nights.
This will be a four week exercise with
Dr. Matthew Emerson Al introduce him
in just a minute. But if you are a guest here at
Henderson Hills Baptist Church, we want
to say welcome and we don't believe that it's an accident
that you're here. We've prayed that you would come and
so tonight you're an answer to our prayers and we have a QR code
and if you don't know what that means.
Just gonna have to come talk to me later. Okay, but if
you'll just take a picture of that it'll take it to a website. You can fill out a
card. We'd love to have a record of your visit to just let you know. Thank you for coming. What
is equipping. Well,
there are many verses in Scripture that
talk about how we are to equip one another that's
our vision to equip one another to love Jesus and to
live sin. And so Dr. Emerson from Oklahoma
Baptist University has a co-authored
more than 20 books and is
responsible for one that that stuck out to me called
the story of scripture.
And so if you think about it, the Bible isn't a collection
of laws or lessons. It's it's
not just lists of
genealogies. It's a collection of stories stories about
people and events and families and Nations and
kingdoms and I believe that
in these four weeks that Dr. Emerson is going
to help us fall even deeper in love with God's story and I
got this off of his book flap. Okay. So
this isn't mine in Academia, you
have to cite your sources. And so I got this off his book. It's one
big written by one author the holy spirit
with one subject Jesus Christ. And so
we're thrilled to have him here. I'm gonna lead us
in a prayer and then when I'm done praying, I'm gonna say
well welcome Dr. Matthew Emerson and you guys are gonna spontaneously bust
loose with this abrarious Applause.
Welcome him to our church. All right, let's pray
together father. Thank you so much for your word and
Lord we know.
That it sharpens us that it equips us that it rebukes and
corrects us and instructs Us in
righteousness. And so Lord. Let us become not just
familiar with the word, but obedient with your word and
we thank you Lord for men who have studied and who have
grasp insights that they're willing to share and we
thank you for Dr. Emerson and Jesus and we pray amen. You
guys get ready to get your hands. Ready. Welcome Dr. Matthew
Emerson.
Thank you, Phil. I was trying to preempt the
uproaria supplies by getting on stage first, but
Didn't succeed in thwarting your efforts. Well, good evening.
I'm very grateful to be here. Thank you Phil for inviting
me. It's my understanding that I'm your the
first guest in this series. Is that right? So and you've
been here for six months, so I'm not gonna pin my
jaw or your job on me, but if I don't do well
don't blame it on Phil. So what I
want to do,
in the next four weeks
is really just walk through the Bible and we're
gonna start in Genesis 1:1 and we're going to
make it all the way to revelation 22 by the end of it. And the
reason why
this is important to me and why I wrote a
book about it and why I like to teach on it is because
I grew up in church.
I grew up in hearing in Sunday school
the different stories that are in the Bible. Mostly the big
ones that we know like The Exodus Noah
and the Ark, you know, the the
stories of Jesus's Miracles his teachings
some of the stories of the book of Acts. I
grew up hearing these stories and I grew up
hearing the gospel.
I grew up hearing that Jesus died for my sins. And if I trusted him
I would be saved.
But I didn't really grow up.
Being taught how the Bible fits together as one book.
and
You know, that's not to blame the church that I grew up in or
anything like that, but it is to say later on in my walk with
the Lord.
It became difficult for me to read
my Bible.
It became difficult for me to open my bible to
a particular book and start reading and say wow. I'm
really getting something from this story about
a person. I've never heard of who I
can't relate to anybody else in the Bible.
It just sounds like
The distant past Jesus has already come why
don't I need to know this stuff?
I would open my bible to you know.
A passage out of the middle of Second Kings and
just go.
Okay, didn't even touch numbers
or Leviticus?
The point of books like Song of Songs
alluded me that's from married people.
You know and it was that sort of approach to understanding
and reading the Bible.
and when I was in school
Thankfully I had some professors who taught me
that the Bible isn't just a collection
of 66 different books.
That have really not a whole lot to do with each other other than
maybe some of the stories carry over and ultimately this
whole book is centered on
Jesus, but that these 66 books
actually comprise one book.
That the 66 books from Genesis to Revelation aren't just
kind of thrown together, but that they fit
together like a puzzle.
And just like when you put a puzzle together correctly where
all the pieces match and they're putting the right place. It
makes this whole picture.
The same thing is true of the books of the Bible and the different stories
in those books. Then when you put them together when you see how
they fit together.
What you see is a picture.
in the pictures of Jesus
and so what I want to do over the next four weeks is just walk you
through the Bible.
We're not going to read every verse in the
Bible. So hopefully that lessens the stress level a
little bit. I want to walk you through the whole Bible want
to see how this whole book. This.
One book is a book about one person. Jesus
written by one author the Holy Spirit.
And in doing that I hope that it'll help honestly. I
hope it'll just help your devotional life.
I hope it'll help you want to read the Bible.
I hope it will help you overcome some of the obstacles you
found in trying to read your Bible at different parts of
the Bible.
and
I want you to see how seeing the Bible as
one book and hearing all these different ways
the Bible fits together. I want you to see how that impacts your own
daily life.
God has made the world for a purpose.
He's made you for a purpose.
Sin has affected our ability to relate to God
into one another but he has sent his son Jesus.
To die for our sins and to redeem what Adam lost.
And that matters for your daily life.
That matters how you live and work and relate to each other how
you interact with your family how you talk to
your friends?
So I want you to see not just how the Bible is one
book by how that one book is transformative for your life. Okay, so
we're going to start in the very beginning. So if you have a Bible
Let's look at Genesis 1.
I am gonna read quite a bit of Genesis 1
and to be honest with you. I'm not
sure we're gonna make it out of Genesis 3 tonight. Okay, so just
be prepared.
To stay in the beginning of Genesis. We might we'll see.
It depends. It depends on how many weird faces
Aaron Miller makes at me during this entire thing.
So
Genesis 1 and on the slides
on the screen. These are really just for you to be
able to follow along but as
we begin I'm gonna work through
the Bible in four big plot points. So if
you think about a story there are different kinds
of plot points or points along the
way we're significant things happen. You can group the
story in a different parts. You can think about
it in terms of chapters.
The Bible has four of those four big plot points
for big chapters for big categories. However,
you want to say that.
And the first one of those is creation.
In creation lasts for the part of
the Bible that deals specifically with creation lasts two
chapters. Of course, there are other chapters in the Bible that address creation
but the Bible telling us about what happened and what
creation is for just last for two chapters the first
two chapters of Genesis.
And on the screen what you're going to see is a summary of
what we're about to walk through. So you're welcome to
write those down. But as I tell my students.
In class the point really isn't the PowerPoint slide.
The point is for you to have a kind of outline for
how we're going to walk through these two chapters.
Okay. So as we as we look
at Genesis 1, let's just read together and I'll read it. You don't have to
read it out loud with me, but we'll read together. Let's start in
verse 1 and I'm just going to read and point out some things as we read.
So Genesis 1 verse 1 in the beginning God created the
heavens and the Earth.
The Earth was without form and void and darkness was over
the face of the deep and the spirit of God was hovering over
the face of the waters.
And God said let there be light and there
was light.
And God saw that the light was good and God
separated the light from the darkness.
God called the light day and the Darkness he called night and there
was evening and there was mourning the first
day now is I'm going to keep reading but as we read what I want you to do is
pay attention to the things that are repeated.
Okay, verse 6 and God said let there
be an expanse in the midst of the waters and let it
separate the waters from the waters and God made the
expanse and separated from the waters that were under the expanse from
the waters that were above the expanse and it was so
and God called the expanse heaven and there was
evening and there was morning the second day. You should
already hear some repetition here.
Verse 9 and God said let the waters under the heavens be
gathered together into one place and let the dry land appear and it
was so.
God called the dry land Earth and the
waters that were gathered together. He called seas and God saw
that it was good. And God said let the Earth Sprout
vegetation plants yielding seed and fruit
trees it bearing fruit. And which is their seed each according to
its kind on the earth, and it was so
The Earth brought forth vegetation plants yielding
seed according to their own kinds and trees bearing fruit
in which is their seed each according to its own kind and
God saw that it was good.
And there was evening and there was morning.
The third day, let's just pause right there.
You're welcome to say these out loud or Sam
in your head. Whatever you want. But what are some what
are some repeated words and phrases?
That you heard there in those first three days.
anybody bold enough to say something out loud and God said
Okay, what else?
Separation. Yep, there are things being separated from
each other.
It was good.
God saw that it was good, right he said it
and it happened and then he saw that it was good.
He was separating first light from dark and then
Heavens from sea and then Land from
the sea.
It these things are good.
And there was evening and there was morning the first day the
second day the third day.
What's he created in these first three days? Let's just think about that for a
second.
What is he making?
And that it might be easier to answer that question. Once we get to the next three days,
okay, but I want you to hold that question in your mind for a second. What's he what's
the pattern here?
What is he making the first three days and then what is he making the second three days, so
let's continue.
in verse 14
and God said let there be so once again repetition let
there be lights in the expanse of the Heavens to separate
the day from the night and let them be for signs and
for seasons and for days and years and let them be lights
in the expanse of the Heavens to give light upon the Earth.
and it was so
and God made the two great lights the greater light to Rule the Day
and the Lesser light to rule the night and the Stars.
And God set them in the expanse of the Heavens to
give light on the earth to rule over the day and over the night and
to separate the light from the darkness.
And God saw that it was good and there was
evening and there was morning the fourth day.
Verse 20 and God said let the water swarm of swarms living
creatures and let birds fly above the Earth across the expanse
of the heavens.
So God created the great sea creatures and every living
creature that moves with which the water swarm according to their kinds and
every Winged Bird according to its kind and God saw that
it was good.
And God blessed them saying be fruitful and multiply and
fill the waters in the seas and let Birds multiply on
the Earth.
And there was evening and there was morning the fifth
day.
And God said let the Earth bring forth living creatures
according to their kinds livestock and
creeping things. I could have done without those but God saw that
it was good and beasts of the Earth according to their kinds and
it was so
and God made the beasts of the Earth according to their kinds and the livestock
according to their kinds and everything that Creeps in the ground according to its kind
and God saw that it was good.
My parentheses even spiders then God said
verse 28. I have to remind myself of
that. Let us make man in our image.
After our likeness and let them have dominion over
the fish of the sea and over the birds of the heavens and over the livestock and
over all the Earth and over every creeping thing that creeps on
the earth. So God created man in his own image in the image of
God. He created him male and female. He created him. He
created them.
so notice this pattern
that happens.
On the first day. God separates what?
Not yet light from dark, right?
on the first day God separates light from dark
on the fourth day.
What does God make?
And you can you can look back down on your Bible.
What does he make on the fourth day?
Sun and the moon and the stars.
On the second day.
God separates what?
The waters. What is he what is he making?
sky and the sea
And on the fifth day, he makes what?
You can look again.
fish and
birds
And then on the sixth day.
He separates. What from what?
the land from the sea
and he makes what?
Livestock creeping things Beasts of the field
and then ultimately finally human beings.
So do you see the pattern there?
The light is filled with the heavenly bodies.
The sea in the sky are filled with the
fish and the birds.
The land is filled.
With animals, yes, but ultimately with human beings
who are told to be fruitful and multiply and fill the
Earth.
So there's already something being told to us
about why God makes the world in Genesis 1
in this pattern.
The purpose for creation is for God's
people.
human beings
His Image bears
to dwell in God's place
the land
that's the reason.
Why God makes the world?
For God's people human beings image bears.
to dwell with him in his place
Okay. So already we're seeing something about why God makes the
world this none of this is on your slides.
and what I'm about to say isn't on there either but
It's really important to.
See the order.
And I don't just mean the number the numerical word that we just walked through. I
mean the fact that God has intentionality. He
means to make what he makes.
any means to make it in the order he makes it that's a really
important point that Genesis 1 is making that Moses is
making in these in this first chapter because in ancient
near Eastern times
Other cultures didn't believe that about creation.
I'm not going to go into the Gory details.
But creation of the earth and people
and everything else was a highly chaotic.
I visceral like really gross is what
I'm trying to say process.
It was disgusting.
So just imagine what you're going to imagine right now and make it
10 times worse and you might be getting close to what what other
ancient peoples believed about creation.
The gods would fight and love each other
and the results of those things are creation.
And it's sort of as random as a blood spatter.
Well here.
God isn't making the world.
because of Chaos
But in fact his order he brings order to
the chaos.
Through his own words, not through fighting or
loving.
But through speaking.
and so
What we see in Genesis 1 is that creation itself
at creation as a whole everything that's here
exists for a reason. It's not random. It's
not chaotic. It's intended by God.
And we see that there's a specific intention to that namely
that God's people are going to dwell in God's place.
Human beings are not an accident.
Human beings are not an annoyance to the
gods human beings are image Bears
of God. They are representatives of his
authority, which we're going to talk about in just a second.
Okay. So the first thing we want to see in the
story of the Bible is that God intends for his people to
dwell with him in his place and I'm saying that
over and over and over again because it is
critical.
For us to get that at the beginning to understand the rest of
the story.
Let's continue in.
Verse 29. So we've read that there made in
God's image human beings are that he wants them to
be for multiply verse 29 and God said behold. I
have given you every plant yielding seed that is on the face of all the
Earth and every tree with seed and it's fruit.
You shall have them for food.
Into every beast of the earth and every bird of the heavens
and everything that creeps on the earth everything that has the breath of life. I
have given every green plant for food and it was so
and God saw everything that he had made and behold. It was very good.
And there was evening and there was morning the sixth day.
Chapter 2 verse 1 that's the heavens and the Earth were finished
and all the hosts all the host
of them and on the seventh day God finished his work that
he had done and he rested on the seventh day from all his work that he
had done. So God blessed the seventh day and made it. Holy because on
it God rested from all his work that he had done in creation.
So before we jump to the rest of this slide,
which is focusing in on image bearing. I
just want to say one more thing about this pattern.
One of the repetitions that we saw was that God saw that
it was good.
And then at the end we saw that God saw that
it was very good.
After he made everything.
Just very briefly and we'll come back to this probably in the
last week. If not more often than that and look
God doesn't make junk.
And what he's made he doesn't just throw away.
God cares about me and you
but he cares about everything that he's made.
So God saw that it was good. So I
was very good and then he rested now when
we turn our attention, this is what Genesis
2 does right? So we have two creation accounts Genesis 1 Genesis
2 when we zoom in on human
beings
We're going to find more information about what got
intends for us to be his image Bears. So if
you want to think about this way Genesis 1 is kind of like a wide angle
lens. Look at creation.
Here's the whole thing.
You know, by the way on day six created human beings image
bears.
Genesis 2 is the zoom lens onto that particular
event. God creating human beings.
Okay, so as we look at Genesis 2 what we're going to find is a
little bit more about what God does and intends for
human beings as His Image bears and I'm not going to necessarily read all of
chapter 2 like we just did.
But I do want you to notice a few things.
First of all, look at verse 7, then the Lord God formed
the man of dust from the ground and breathed
into his nostrils the Breath of Life.
And the Man became a living
creature.
And the Lord God planted a garden and Eden in the East and there he
put the man whom he had formed.
And out of the ground the Lord God made to spring up every tree that
is Pleasant to the sight and good for food. The tree of
life was in the midst of the garden and the tree of the knowledge of Good and Evil.
A river flowed out of Eden to water
the garden and there it divided and became Four Rivers.
The name of the first is the Pichon it is
the one that flowed around the whole land of havilah where there is gold.
And the gold of that land is good bedelium and
Onyx Stone are there.
The name of the second river is the GUI home. It is the one
that float around the whole land of kush and the name of the third river
is the Tigris which flows east of Assyria and the
fourth river is the Euphrates and you might think to yourself.
Okay, great. It was pretty
it's a garden.
But but Moses is giving you.
Moses is giving you a
more specific picture than that
This Garden.
is described
like a temple
God puts Adam inside a temple.
Why?
Because that's what human beings are made for.
To worship God and be in his presence.
And this is going to be really important as we look at say Ezekiel 40 through
48 when God promises to rebuild the Temple.
the rebuilt Temple looks like the Garden of Eden why
because the purpose of the Temple
To put you in the presence of God.
That's where God puts Adam in the beginning.
So he makes this Garden Temple for
Adam.
And in verse 16, he gives Adam instructions or verse 15.
He gives Adam instructions the Lord God took the man and put him
in the Garden of Eden to work it and keep it which is the same two verbs that
Moses uses later on to
describe the work of the priests. Adam is a priest in a
temple.
Go in the garden work it and keep it and the Lord God commanded the man
saying you may surely eat of every tree of the garden. But of the tree of
the knowledge of Good and Evil you shall not eat.
For in the day that you eat of it. You shall surely die.
So God puts his people and we're
going to see the creation of Eve in just a second. He puts his people.
in his place
and he gives him his word to obey.
God puts his people in his place and he gives him his word to
obey that is the purpose of creation.
That is the purpose of human beings for them
to dwell in God's place and obey his word.
The purpose of humanity isn't
well, there are lots of things we can mention right the purpose of
humanity isn't to become famous. The purpose of
humanity isn't to be vain glorious. The purpose of humanity isn't to
be comfortable or rich or safe.
or powerful
or rule over other people or to care
for their families. I mean, although some of those things at least
like caring for your families are good things. That's not their ultimate purpose.
The ultimate purpose of human beings is to live with God forever and
obey his word.
That's not what the ancient near East would have said the cultures
around Israel. It's not what our culture
today says.
And we'll find out.
About that in just a second when we get into chapter 3.
Verse 18 the Lord God said is not good
that the man should be alone. I will make a help help or
fit for him.
Now out of the ground the Lord God had formed every beast of the field and every
bird of the heavens and brought them to the man to see what he would call them and whatever
the man called every living creature that was its name the
man gave names to all livestock and to the birds of
the heavens and every beast of the field.
But for Adam there was not found to help her fit for him. So the Lord
God caused a deep sleep to fall upon the man and while he
slept took one of his ribs and closed up its place with flesh.
And the red that the Lord God had taken from the man he made into a woman
and brought her to the man. Then the man
said this at last is bone of my bones and Flesh of My
Flesh.
She shall be called woman because she was taken out of
man.
Therefore a man shall leave his father and his mother and hold fast to
his wife.
And they shall become one flesh.
In the man and his wife were both naked and we're not ashamed.
Remember how I pronounce that they were naked? Okay. It's
gonna be important a second.
Listen God, I've labored this enough. God makes
his people Adam and Eve to live in his place
this Garden temple in obey his word.
That's why they exist.
If we were to sum up everything that we've seen in Genesis 1
and 2 that God says about Humanity it
is that image bearing consists of the following.
Adam and Eve are supposed to have dominion
over the whole earth. They're supposed to rule.
And I'm going to say these four things a lot
over the next four weeks. Okay, so just get ready to hear these repeated over
and over and over again.
God makes human beings to rule or have dominion over
the whole Earth.
They're supposed to be representatives of
his authority.
In the ancient near East if you were a king and you
were called an image bear it was because you represented the
authority of the god that you served.
Adam and Eve or if you made a statue same thing Adam
and Eve are living representatives of God's
Authority in this place that he's made
for them the only God.
Right. No, there's no other God in Genesis 1 is there.
There's nothing else in Genesis 1 besides God until
he makes it.
Adam and Eve are the living representatives of
the authority of the one true God rule.
They rule over God's place.
Secondly God tells them to obey his
word. They're supposed to rule well.
by obeying well
God tells him to rule he doesn't to obey and then
he tells them to be fruitful and multiply.
So God doesn't want it to just be Adam and Eve forever. He wants
them to make more image bearers.
Make more representatives of yahweh's authority
throughout the whole earth fill the Earth.
with worshipers of Yahweh
and then he finally tells them and we just read it. He tells Adam specifically
but this is also free to cultivate and keep
the garden care for God's place
It's supposed to rule over it.
Obey God's word.
Be fruitful multiply care for creation. Those
are the four tasks.
That God gave to Adam and Eve.
rule obey
be fruitful and care for God's place.
ultimately
Ultimately, the purpose God has for mankind
for humankind.
Is to dwell with him and worship him. That's it.
That's why we exist.
Now, why do I belabor Genesis
1 and 2 so much why have I talked for a
good half hour?
about two chapters of the Bible
when we're supposed to get through the whole thing.
in four weeks
and I'm going to say the same thing about Genesis 3 in just a
second if we don't understand.
Why God made what he made?
We won't understand what he does when
he redeems it.
If we don't understand why God made what he made why God
made what he made We're Not Gonna understand what he's doing.
When he comes himself in the person of his son.
incarnate
to save it to redeem it.
We have to understand the beginning to understand
the end.
a lot of times when we read Genesis 1
and 2
we read Genesis 1 and 2 just for
I don't want to quite say argumentative purposes, but maybe that's the
right word to use. We read it for argumentative purposes.
We want to argue with somebody who thinks the world was
made by atheistic Evolution. We
want to argue with somebody who thinks that marriage is not
just between one man. And one woman we want to argue with somebody who
thinks XYZ about whatever issue.
And yes.
The Bible does provide us with good arguments in
defense of our faith.
But more fundamentally Genesis 1 and 2
is giving us a vision for what life should have
been.
Had sinned not entered the world.
And therefore it's giving us a vision of what it will be.
when Jesus returns in glory
okay, so that's that's why we're belaboring Genesis 1 and
2 and also to see
As we turn and you want to turn to Genesis 3 as we
see the effects of sin on this
creation. So we've talked through the first chapter of
the Bible in the creation narrative.
Now, we want to go to chapter 2, which is chapter three
of Genesis, but chapter 2 of our story The Bible second plot
point the fall.
And again, this only takes up one chapter.
But if you can if you can get the first three chapters of Genesis.
That's going to go a long long way for
you to understand the rest of the Bible.
okay, so Genesis 3
and I'm gonna read Porsche significant portions
of this now the serpent was more crafty than
any other beast of the field that the Lord God had made
notice that for I mean just I just kind of want you guys to read really
closely with me for a little bit notice that now the
serpent was more crafty than what
Any other beast of the field?
What what did?
What did God just give Adam authority over?
every beast of the field
this serpent shows up and this is some this is something that Adam
already has been given authority over.
And yet he said to the woman and you got I
mean you got to notice.
He said to the woman did God actually
say.
there is not a Temptation known to man that
did not begin with did God actually say
don't do that.
If you think about any Temptation you've ever faced.
the serpent subtly Whispers in your ear
God actually say you shouldn't do that.
And notice what he does did God actually say you shall not eat.
Of any tree in the garden, is that what God actually said?
No, we just read it.
He didn't tell Adam not to eat of any tree.
Eve to her credit gets it right. She says
the woman said to the servant. Well, she gets right at first we may eat
of the fruit of the trees in the garden, but God said You shall not
eat of the fruit of the tree that is in the midst of the garden so far so good.
Neither shall you touch it lest? You die. Did
God ever tell Adam and Eve not to touch the tree?
No.
I told him not to eat. It didn't say don't touch it. That's probably
not a good idea to touch it. I mean, that's fair.
But he never says that so Eve responds sort
of.
Correctly to this question.
But the serpent first attacks God's word.
Did God actually say the first attack in temptation
is to attack God's word. Did God actually
say don't do this.
Eve to her credit
gets it mostly right here and says well, yeah, he told us not
to eat of this fruit.
So the serpent shifts tactics, okay.
It says the serpent.
verse 4
you will not surely die.
For God knows that when you eat of it your eyes will be opened and you will
be like God knowing Good and Evil.
The serpent shifts from questioning God's word. Did
God really say?
to questioning God's love
Okay. Yeah, maybe he did tell you not to do that. But you know why?
Because he doesn't want you to be like him.
He'll be jealous.
It's not it's not a good rule.
To rule he made up for his own jealousy.
And we hear this we hear this
all the time.
in our culture
on issues of gender and sexuality did God
really say
don't do this.
And here's how you hear that today.
It's not quite that obvious. It's well that law
is in the Old Testament.
And we don't have to obey that anymore.
That's still a version of they've got
actually say don't do this.
But the other way and this is the much more prominent means by which Satan
attacks these days at least in my opinion.
Is if God really loved you.
He wouldn't tell you not to do that.
If God really loved you.
He'd let you do what you want in this area of your life.
If God really loved you, he'd understand.
Why you want to do this and it would be okay.
Some versions of that are just God loves you and accepts
you as you are.
Doesn't expect anything different of you. That's how we hear that
in our culture. And that's what Satan is doing. He's saying listen if God
really loved you.
If he actually cared about you and not
just about himself.
He wouldn't prohibit this.
He cheer you on.
Have you heard that? Do you know I mean do you resonate with
that kind of Temptation This is
what Satan is doing and if he's not doing it to you. I can guarantee you
he's doing it to your kids or your grandkids or your
nieces or your nephews or your kids in your class?
Because that is what my kids are hearing
all the time in school.
If God really loved you if God was a
god of love.
He wouldn't prohibit this or that.
That's exactly what Satan does the beginning he doesn't change his ways. He's not smart
enough to do that.
He's doing the same old thing that he was doing since the
beginning questioning God's word questioning God's love.
Verse 6. So when the woman saw that the tree noticed
that
Look at this. So when the woman saw that the tree was good.
What do you hear?
And God saw that it was good.
And there was evening it was morning. Well now Eve saw
that it was good not by God's estimation.
but by her own
God's Eve saw that it was good for food that
it was a delight to the eyes that the
tree was to be desired to make one wise. She took of
its fruit and ate.
And she also gave some to her husband who was with her and he
ate I guess Adams just lounging around back here while this Serpent's talking
to his wife.
Then the eyes of both were open verse 7
and they knew that they were naked.
Somebody knew the difference and they sewed fig leaves together and made
themselves loin claws.
And they heard the sound of the Lord God Walking In The
Garden in the cool of the day.
In the man and his wife hid himself from the presence of
the Lord God Among the Trees of the garden.
These okay. Look I'm from Alabama. So I
like read things in Alabama. And so when
I see this and I kind of think about
my parents acting like they couldn't
find me playing hide and seek but the Lord God called the
man and said then where you at and he said I heard the
sound of some of you in the garden.
Or answer the sound of you in the garden. I was afraid because I was naked.
And I hid myself and he said who told you that you
were naked not naked. Have you eaten of the
tree of which I commanded you not to eat? Okay, look you all know the
difference between naked and naked.
This is my grandma taught me this long time ago.
Naked is when you ain't got no clothes on.
Nick it is when you ain't got no clothes on you're doing something y'all not to be doing. Okay. So
Adam and Eve went from knowing they were
naked knowing they were naked and
verse 12
after God asked him notice this he said who told you
that you were naked. Have you eaten up the tree which
I commanded you not to eat. Of course. He knows the answer to this but he's as he's
asking them to confess.
Of course God knows what happened, but he's he's putting them
in the process of confession instead
of confessing. What does Adam do?
What we all do the man said that old woman over there
whom he gave to be with me. She gave me the fruit of the tree and I ate
Then the Lord God said to the woman. Okay, what's this
you have done? And the woman said it was that snake over there? That made
me.
both of them
shift the blame
to someone else
and this is what we all do.
when we sin
Satan hasn't changed his tactics.
And human beings haven't changed our response.
None of us are wise enough for either.
Satan won't wise up. Neither will we?
Every time we sin.
What's our first reaction?
I can guarantee you most of us unless you
are the most Sanctified person on the earth who you might be sitting in here chances
are you're not but maybe you are.
maybe it's all of you and I'm just the only one here is still a sinner, but my first
reaction at least is
look
Okay, this is what happened.
Like I only did this because
Like this guy was in front of me, and he was going really slow and
was making me really mad. I was late to work and the only
reason I started yelling and getting mad is because I didn't want to miss my meeting.
Anger. Okay. Yeah, but I mean, that's what
we do.
We blame somebody else.
For our sin, and that's exactly what Adam and Eve done do and
so then the Lord turns to the snake.
In this the snake, there's no response. He's just like yeah the Lord
God said to the serpent because you have done this cursed. Are
you above all livestock?
And above all Beasts of the field on your belly. You
shall go and dust you shall eat all the days of your life.
I will put enmity between you and the woman and between your Offspring and
her Offspring. He shall bruise your head and you shall Bruce his heal. We're
going to come back to that.
in a little bit, but notice what he
says to the woman and the man so the woman he said
I will surely multiply your pain in childbearing.
In pain, you shall bring forth children your desire
shall be for your husband and he shall rule
over you.
And before we move on to what he says to Adam,
I just want you to notice.
So what are the effects of sin?
on Eve
it's going to hurt when you have babies.
And you're not going to want to make babies because you're always going to be mad at your
husband.
Is essentially what that is?
In pain all the women are laughing and none of them men are so
like it's gonna hurt when you have babies in pain.
You shall bring forth children.
Not only that but the the means
of bringing forth children procreating with
your husband your desire is going to be for him,
but he will rule over you. There will be Strife in your
relationship.
It's going to be hard to have babies and to make babies. And what does
that affect in terms of those tasks?
That we went over.
Rule. Obey care
And what?
Be fruitful and multiply.
It's going to be hard to be fruitful multiply when you don't want to be fruitful and
it's going to hurt to multiply.
That's essentially What's Happening Here?
And then notice what he says to Adam.
Verse 17 to Adam. He said by the way, my wife
when we we had Grace her epidural didn't work.
And some of y'all are like why did she even need an epidural but I support my
wife. It was great. I was like, yeah get an epidural. I don't care and so
she gets one and it doesn't work which is a real thing and in
the middle of Labor she just says why did
Eve have to eat the fruit so
I mean, I feel like that's probably something most women Proclaim during childbirth at
least in their heads to Adam. He said because you have
listened to the voice of your wife and remember that phrase by the way, we probably
won't get to the next instance of it tonight. But
just remember that to Adam he said because you have listened to
the voice of your wife.
Rather than what right? It's not. I mean the issue is
not listening to your wife. That's not the problem.
Because you have listened to the voice of your wife instead of
what?
the voice of God
The issue isn't that Adam was you know?
Being an effeminate Man by listening to his wife the
issue was that he listened to someone else's voice?
Rather than God's voice.
That's the problem.
Which makes him by the way fail in his task as a
man?
says to Adam
because you have listened to the voice of your wife.
And have eaten of the okay. I got
to stop again. Think about what we heard in Genesis 1, what
did you hear over and over and over and over and over and over and over
again?
And God said
the voice that we hear
in Genesis 1 and 2 loud and clear
the repetition the power The Authority that
we hear in Genesis 1 and 2 is the voice of
the one true and living God.
In the voices that we hear in Genesis 3 when?
The serpent shows up are not the voice of God, but the
voice of the serpent and then the voice of his wife.
And again, the issue is not listening
to your wife or whatever. The issue is.
Here's this voice, which it makes sense to listen to.
The voice of the only true and living God and you've
listened to some other voice over here.
What what Moses is doing is trying to show us how?
and I'm sorry if I offend you I'm talking about myself here how
stupid
we are as human beings.
we have
the word of the Living God
right here.
And what do we choose to listen to most of time? What do I choose
to listen to I choose to listen to my own voice?
To the voice of the serpent to the voice of somebody else who's giving
me bad advice.
again, maybe maybe everybody in this room is going to be denied it
as a saint on Pond death, but for me at least
I'm still struggling with that.
And that's what Moses is showing us here in Genesis
1 and 2 and this is going to matter for the story of Israel because Israel
over and over again, here's directly from
the mouth of God.
And then they go and listen to somebody else.
I'm I can't help but get ahead of myself and then Jesus shows up.
And he gets baptized.
In the heavens open the dove descends and the voice of
the father says this is my son.
My beloved Son whom I'm well pleased what listen to
him?
So he says because you have listened to the voice of
your wife.
And have eaten of the tree of which I commanded you you
shall not eat of it. This is like what with our
kids, you know, it's like you remember that remember when I said don't do
that.
Then you did it. I said don't do that. That's what
God is saying.
Hey kid
Remember how I said don't eat of it. You just
eight of it cursed is the ground because of you.
notice cursed
Is the serpent above all livestock cursed is the ground?
Because of Adam this is in contrast to the goodness
of creation later on. It's in contrast to the
blessing over Abraham.
In pain, you shall eat of it all the days of your
life Eve in pain. You shall bring forth children Adam in
pain you shall eat from the ground.
thorns and thistles it shall bring forth for you rather than
the plants that yielded food in
Genesis 1 the green things.
And you shall eat the plants of the field?
By the sweat of your face, you shall eat bread.
So you return to the ground for out of it you were taken
for your dust.
Into dust you shall return.
What's this? What does this affect? What does Sin affect
for Adam?
For Eve, it was beef fruitful and multiply for Adam. It's care for
creation.
Adams told to cultivate and keep the garden.
To work it and to keep it.
And what God is saying here is your work is going to be futile.
Rather than bringing forth green things to eat. It's going
to bring forth thorns and thistles.
sin
effects
everything
sin affects
everything every aspect of creation.
Think about what we've just heard.
now what we focus on and rightly so out of this chapter
is
and we haven't read all the way through chapter 3. Let me just I'll just
read chapter 3 the end very quickly verse 20 of the man called his wife's
name Eve because she was the mother of the living.
And the Lord God Made For Adam and for his wife garments of skins and
clothed them.
Then the Lord God said behold the man has become like
one of us and knowing good and evil now lest he reach
out his hand and take also of the tree of life and eat and live forever. Therefore
the Lord God sent him out from the Garden of Eden
to work the ground from which he was taken.
He drove out the man and at the east of the Garden of Eden,
he placed the cherubim and a flaming sword that turned every way
to guard.
the way to the Tree of Life
now
notice sin affects everything and
especially we rightly focus
on this especially our relationship with the Lord.
death enters the world both physical and spiritual
to dust you shall return physical death.
And they're kicked out of God's presence spiritual death.
sin breaks
our relationship with God
but notice what else sin does as
ultimately important as that is right. The rest
of these are not as important as the fact that our relationship with
God is broken, but they're still important notice the rest
of these listen affects Adam and Eve's
relationship with each other.
Number one, they're both going to die and probably
not at the same time. So death breaks relationships.
But also remember what he says the eve not just pain in
childbearing but there's gonna be Strife between you and
your husband.
Sin affects us.
vertically our relationship to God
But it also affects us horizontally if we kept reading in Genesis 4,
we see that relational break.
even
more dramatically with Cain and Abel and then lamech.
murdering each other
sin affects our relationship with God it affects our relationship with
each other and it also affects our relationship with creation itself.
Cursed is the ground.
Because Of You the ground the land remember God's
people and God's place
This place that God made for you now, it's cursed because
of you.
Fix our relationships vertically horizontally and
with creation itself, but it also affects our ability
to do what God made us to do.
What didn't Adam and Eve do in the garden?
That they were supposed to do out of those four things. What did they not do?
The easiest one is they didn't obey.
right
How about Adam should have karate chopped that serpent into
nothing the second he entered the garden. They didn't rule well
either.
We'll see that later with Israel Israel supposed to drive out the enemies of
God from the land and what do they do instead?
They let him just sit there.
and talk kind of like
Adam did with the serpent, right?
They don't obey they don't rule.
that's
Sin, they don't obey because they don't rule.
And therefore they are no longer able to
in the way that God intended be fruitful and multiply or care
for creation.
everything beautiful
that we saw in Genesis 1 and
2 has been broken by Adam and Eve sin.
Everything beautiful that we saw in Genesis 1
and 2 has been broken by Adam and Eve sin.
to the point where
there's no way for Adam and Eve to get back in.
What does God do at the end of Genesis 3 he puts two
cherubim two angels and not like the ones that
you see on Precious Moments.
But like six wings eyes all around kind of weird stuff puts
two angels with flaming swords.
on either side of the garden
everything beautiful in Genesis 1 and 2 has been broken by
sin Adam and Eve sin and Genesis 3
And there's no way for them to get back in.
now, of course the beautiful thing
in the midst of the Brokenness is that God provides hope
so we'll I'm going to give you a very brief a few
comments on Genesis 3 and
hope but for the rest of our time.
What we're going to do is next week. We'll walk through
the story of Israel.
And walk through the promises that God makes to
restore what Adam lost.
In the third week. We'll talk about how Jesus fulfills
those promises to restore. What Adam lost.
in the gospels and acts
and then in the final week, we'll talk about how we can live in light
of those and then look forward to the second coming of
Jesus when he will bring full and final
Victory and restore what Adam's law
what Adam lost for good but
I don't want to jump too far ahead. So just Genesis 3 again.
God does promise redemption in the midst of
this Brokenness.
He says to the serpent, first of all, and I read this
but didn't comment on it. He says to the serpent.
in verses 14 and 15
because you have done this cursed. Are you above all livestock and
above all Beasts of the field on your belly shall
go and dust you shall eat of it all the days of your life.
And there's so much I want to say but I'm not gonna say it.
Not because it's not.
appropriate
Okay, look just dust I'm gonna say it. Anyway, what's dust
a sign of at the end of this chapter?
From dust you came to us your turn death.
Dust is a sign of death.
It's also a sign of cursing.
Cursed are you you'll eat dust all
the days of your life.
This is just a little nugget. I'm like, I'm just pause for
a second just a little night dust is the sign of cursing separation
from God judgment.
death
after
Israel
fails in the wilderness
What does Moses have to do to?
Intercede for the people do you remember?
Is to grind.
one of the bronze the Bronze Statues
the sign of their Rebellion down to dust and then drink it.
Mix it with the dust of the ground.
It takes judgment in himself.
and then
what does Jesus do?
In The Garden of Gethsemane
He says to God if it's your will let this cup.
pass from me
but not my will but yours be done.
He drinks the cup.
of God's Wrath
These are the kinds of things I mean think about this.
Cursed is the ground because of you from thorns and thorns and
thistles you shall bring forth from it all the days of your life. What is the Ram's Horn
caught in?
In Genesis 22 when?
Abraham takes Isaac up one of the mountain
Thorns and thistles, what is Jesus's crown
made of?
thorns
Right the whole Bible is one book.
pointing to one person Jesus Christ
written by one author of the Holy Spirit
Those I mean, we're probably I'm probably not gonna mention that again, but these little
details that we often just pass over.
That's over that we often just pass over.
Are actually intended by God and
by the human author to signify something namely.
that
everything that was broken by Adam sin
is going to be restored in the person and
work of Jesus Christ.
This is what God promises in Genesis 3
in verse 15. I will put enmity between you and the woman and
between your Offspring and her offspring.
He shall bruise your head and you shall bruise his heel.
This is the first promise of the Gospel in the
Bible.
If you want a big word, I'm not going to spell it out. It's called Proto Evangelion.
I'm not going to say it again because nobody cares but
me but that means First Gospel.
first preaching of the Gospel
This is the first proclamation of the Gospel in the
Bible that God through the seed
of woman. This one man. That's going to come from Eve. God
is going to destroy destroy.
the source of sin
God through the seed of woman is going
to destroy the source of sin and by destroying sin
at its source he is going to restore creation
from all of sin's effects.
when I
first started
seeing these things in the Bible through the help of others.
The Boston Red Sox had just
won the World Series for the first time. I remember
that and and the I don't know about that, but
The slogan if you remember
was reverse the curse, right as they were making the run through the playoffs and
everything was reversed the curse reverse the curse.
And I like to I like to think of Genesis 3:15
as God's promise to reverse the
curse.
He is going not the curse of the Bambino the curse of
Adam. He's going to reverse it through the
seed of woman.
so Redemption
is that third plot point? I don't really want necessarily
the slide up because you guys are gonna start writing and we're
not going to talk about any of it for the rest of the time but the third
chapter of the Bible is redemption and this
stretches from Genesis, 3:15 all the
way to Revelation 20.
So that's the most of the Bible is this chapter on Redemption?
Creation fall Redemption and Revelation 21
and 22 New Creation or restoration? However,
you want to say that.
And this is where Redemption starts this is the
promise that God makes to restore what Adam
lost to reverse the curse of Adam.
There's a couple of other signs that God is not
leaving Adam and Eve just to die without hope
he closed them.
in Genesis, 3:21
And it says that he clothed them.
in garments of skins
now unless it's their own skin, which I'm going to go with
probably not it's the skin of some other
creature.
So more than likely this skin of
another creature comes from the first sacrifice.
That restoration to relationship with God is
somehow related to death blood covering.
Those are all themes that you probably can hear the rest
of the Bible in.
And then he also I mean even in kicking them out notice what he
says about when he kicks them out.
In verse 22 the the second sentence in
verse 22 now.
Lest he reach out his hand and take also of the tree of
life and eat and live forever.
He drives him out what he doesn't let him stay in
the garden not because he doesn't want Adam and
Eve in his presence anymore. But because of Adam and Eve stay.
And they eat from the Tree of Life.
They live in a state of sin of separation from God.
forever
so even driving them out.
Is a sign for them that he's going to bring them back in.
Just one more little thing and I may mention this
again. I don't know but it's
I don't want to miss it if I don't notice that.
In verse 24, I already said he puts these two.
Crazy looking monster things on the
side of the entrance to the garden.
and
so I just I need you to visualize for a second.
Here is a large door.
with two angels standing on
the side
and if you were to be able to walk through that door.
You would be in the presence of God.
in his place
I'm sure I'll bring this up next week, but just just to help
you start and if you already are thinking this way when you read the Bible great, but
if you aren't.
think about this as Israel is told
to build the Tabernacle and then the temple
What stands at the entrance into the temple itself?
two columns
named Boaz and Jakin
and if you were to pass.
Through those two columns you would enter into the presence of the Living
God.
and then
Then sorry I get like little Goosebumps when
I talk think about the Bible sometimes then when Jesus.
On the third day.
when Peter and John arrive at
the tomb
what does it say about what they see at the team?
They saw two angels.
Standing on either side.
if you go in
Where are you? You're in the presence of God, that doesn't make any sense. That's
a tomb.
It's because the presence of God is now in the
person of Jesus Christ who has died and risen
again from the dead.
These are the kinds of things that if you'll just
take close attention to the details.
like this
I don't I don't read this way because you know,
I have certain degrees or whatever. Somebody said to me one
time just pay attention to repeat it things and weird stuff.
And that's all I do. There's not a secret sauce. Just listen
for repeated words and phrases. My students are
like, you know, how do you see those connections? Well,
number one
other people Point them out, but number two.
If you just will read your Bible over and over and over
again.
Which may sound tedious at first if you
will just read it.
These things will start to become apparent to
you.
The biblical authors wrote in such a way that they wanted you
to notice when they repeat stuff.
They want you to notice when you know, Jesus
looks like David.
Or when Jesus looks like Moses or whatever they want
you to see that? Okay. So my encourage you my
encouragement for you for next week is if you
fallen behind on your yearly reading plan as I
have get caught up read the Bible just read it like
don't feel stressed about it. Just read the thing pay attention
to details.
Listen for repeated patterns if there's weird things like, you know.
six six winged
I covered.
Monstrosities with swords like you might want to pay attention to
that. It's weird. That's my encouragement. So here's the
deal Genesis wanted to
God makes the world for a certain purpose and a
certain way God's people in his place rule care be
fruitful and multiply obey.
in the fall in Genesis 3
it all falls apart.
But God's made a promise.
That he's going to reverse the curse of Adam. He's going to restore what
Adam lost through the seed of women and so
next week. We'll start our search for the
seed.